les adeptes du ski de montagne à sports
extrêmes de plus en plus populaire au
canada sauf qu'ils prennent des risques
lors de leur randonnée de ski
d'alpinisme leur escalade répété à flanc
de montagne à coups de ski puis de
descente soudaine à peine contrôlés
souvent effectués dans le vide se
terminent chaque année pour une poignée
d'entre eux en tragédie la championne
cycliste canadienne et athlète olympique
lindsey la motoneige de neige et le ski
de randonnée sont les deux activités les
plus risquées en montagne ils
représentent respectivement 40% et 29 %
de tous les décès enregistrés depuis
l'hiver 2007 and area beaucoup de
banques formé pour sensibiliser des
habitués des sports de montagne des
cours par exemple de deux jours existe
notamment typiquement en janvier et
février
l'instructeur ken bélanger de
l'entreprise adam jones puis sixty five
d'abord il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
vont aller à payer ça devient je vais
pas d'effet à la mode mais disons que
c'est certain que c'est une chose qui
inquiète beaucoup des gens pour
plusieurs raisons sur l' aventure pour
pacy n soul l'estiu les motoneiges et
une seule à la neige poudreuse et on est
content de dire au canada en fait on le
libère dans tous les textes équilibre
des cours d'avalanche dans la profonde
âge des gens qui ont pris ce genre de
cours en éducation
mais on n'a toujours rien faire il ya
toujours du monde qui forment souvent du
mans qui se fait peut-être l'un d'eux
ainsi qu'au comité qui sans intérêt là
l'enjeu qu'il a signé avec pour certains
ceci vaut mieux comme par le court au
départ de l'expérience d' aventure dans
l'arrière-pays depuis trois ans
l'association canadienne des avalanches
et techtera une entreprise spécialisée
en technologies géomatiques
met à la disposition des canadiens des
données fournies par un nouveau logiciel
destiné à aider les professionnels de la
montagne
les skieurs et les militaires canadiens
améliorer leur gestion des risques d
avalanches observé pour la plupart déjà
donc c'est pour ça que l'avalanche
canada c'est pour donner l'information
que la plupart des gens ne seraient pas
capables de trouver eux mêmes et puis
yeux c'est un peu comme la météo on peut
regarder à l'extérieur mais on ne
pourrait pas faire jacques valade et
directeur général du site internet
avalanche canada améliore nos
connaissances à tous les années j'ai
aimé serait ce que c'est quand même
assez risqué puis cette crise est simple
comme lenny et par là dont on essaie
d'améliorer notre potentiel d'affaires
les prévisions juge adéquate si tu
avoues dans les dernières années aussi
sur les nouvelles technologies
la stratégie d'avalanche quintana de
partager l'information sur les sites web
notamment concernant les risques
d'avalanche s'avère dans l'ensemble
succès car malgré la popularité
notamment du ski de randonnée de la
motoneige qui ont explosé dans la
dernière décennie au niveau des
montagnes rocheuses par exemple la
fréquence des décès l'avalanche n'a pas
augmenté
elle elle en fait chuter de 50%
il existe aussi toujours en ligne une
nouvelle application pour prévenir les
avalanche mortelle une initiative
conjointe de avalanche canada et du
gouvernement de l'alberta légumes dans
les montagnes et j'accepte aussi du
transport de la sécurité publique
les municipalités aussi la journaliste
amélie dionne du journal
franco-albertain lefranc courses qui
sont ceux qui vont sur info etc c'est le
logiciel en question
pour mettre à jour de l'information dont
ils ont besoin
leurs observations qu'ils ont fait dans
le dans leur milieu par exemple sa tête
une accumulation neige une avalanche de
tentes est donc ils vont aller suer
sur une carte donc c'est assez précis va
devenir maman ça fait pas assez à quel
endroit aussi dont par exemple pour un
guide un montant qui veut faire une
randonnée pédestre avec un gros peut
aller consulter les données qui sont
mises à jour régulièrement pour
déterminer si vous si c'est trop
dangereux pour lui d'aller avec son gros
tout non il n'ya pas que les skieurs qui
courent des risques bien sûr au sommet
du canada donc le long de certains cols
enneigés des rocheuses canadiennes dans
l'ouest du pays de 12 à 15 mètres de
neige s'accumule parfois chaque hiver
typiquement notamment dans le secteur
qu'on appelle le col rogers il s'agit
d'un des rares endroits au pays où les
canadiens peuvent franchir en auto
watrin les formidables montagne qui
traverse du nord au sud
notre territoire voilà pourquoi les
spécialistes du ministère parcs canada
seconde et par les militaires canadiens
sillonnent jour et nuit le secteur de
l'autoroute qui avoisine le col rogers
au fil des années on n'y a repéré 140
zones à risque donc 140 couloirs
d'avalanche une fois le danger repérer
les militaires sont appelés à déclencher
des explosions à l'aide par exemple
canon au sol encore hélicoptère afin de
hâter la chute de la neige typiquement
au mois de février
l'armée a accompli une dizaine de
missions de tir et lens environ 500 obus
un reportage de radio canada
international